hey how's it going
it's time to watch some pretty pie means
you bros you bros submitted them 250
pages Jesus Ainsley it's free real
estate when you're not a vegan but she
thinks you need a powerful core message
[Music]
these are not funny why am i that phase
when you lost actually I didn't even
care that much they're all inactive
subscribers I'm happy for them to be
gone they just say that you're fine
you're not really fun that feeling when
sorsha makes yoga pants illegal wait
wait
yoga pants are illegal the development
of butterfly yeah it's pretty accurate
mean oh why when you see someone tell
you man those [ __ ] Underpants what
the [ __ ] is that when you're pissed off
but he says something can we not make it
crying kids a thing please thank you
very much yes mom he makes money in fish
yeah my mom still doesn't believe it
either it's okay That moment when you
see your mom and me
when you gotta get down on her but she's
I'm so immature when the Swedish
meatball has a good spice it's so bad
this rare photo of soldier about to
storm the beaches oh man I don't know if
I'm tired or why but this is really
funny
hey you sorry for YouTube - yeah I love
Malcolm 1466 hey Malcolm is on our side
now guys Malcolm is one of us hey it's a
poop eyebrows mom why you never remember
my name I'm a sorry
attempting a sexy cosplay expectation
[Music]
nice I see what you did there that's do
you think that I bet you think you're
clever when both your girlfriends I've
has better have better beards yeah has
47 million subs four million people
watching oh yeah you think that's funny
Oh only four million only what have I
done to deserve such a sweet fanbase
that is just so nice to me and just
shows so much love and always likes my
videos always writing positive comments
always has a positive core message you
bros are just the best yeah
one does not simply make YouTube without
a car that's a good mean that's a good I
can appreciate that mean please start
the app sure but she's talking that's
funny that's really fun what we don't
look alike at all oh my god [ __ ] say oh
my god god damn it that's my screensaver
now that's my [ __ ] screensaver right
there and the diamond play button goes
to
I mean the winner actually is
[Music]
I love the jacksepticeye me yeah that
was really fun I really enjoy that I
really enjoy that you bros take my
videos or whatever and you make your own
kind of humor I really enjoyed that you
bros have a great sense of humor and I
really enjoy the interaction between you
and me that's why I like reading the
comments I think it's fun that we're all
part of a universe the Buddha put the
pootie verse I really do I think that's
it's important and I appreciate you
thank you so much for all the
submissions we're gonna announce a new
competition for two weeks from now it's
gonna be a peopie remix we did one of
these probably five years ago and it was
[ __ ] awesome you can remix whatever
you want pewdiepie related I'm gonna add
some samples so you can download as well
all the info is down in description I
just really appreciate you bros doing
this I think it's so much fun it makes
me I feel like we're finally back and I
look it sounds forced but I really feel
like I used to have such a great
connection with you bros back in the day
and then my channel got way too big and
I just didn't know how to handle with it
and I think with these sort of stuff I
finally feel like we're getting I still
had that again and I really appreciate
that I think that's it means a lot to me
by